ich freue mich sehr dass britta
haßelmann die fraktionsvorsitzende der
grünen gehe bei uns ist ein guter tag
wir haben gerade im beitrag gehört so
ein stück weit kündigt sich für die
grünen ziemlicher spagat an einmal
zwischen politik reagieren und
gleichzeitig basisarbeit mit all dem was
sie mit den harten mühlen die jetzt
schon so zu sagen ob sie zugekommen sind
taxonomie die thematik auch der ukraine
krise impfpflicht debatte und so weiter
sie müssen dann auch mehrheiten
organisieren für ihre partei vor echte
herausforderungen stehen sie da aber das
ist ja genau das wofür unsere partei
seit jahren gekämpft hat und worum wir
auf geworben haben dass wir mehr
unterstützung bekommen mehr bürgerinnen
und würde uns ihr vertrauen geben damit
wir in regierungsverantwortung kommen
und von da aus gestalten können und klar
jetzt kommt einiges neues auf uns zu auf
dem bundesvorstand auf die
bundestagsfraktion auf diejenigen bei
uns die regierungsmitglieder sind und
auf die base aber jetzt muss ich schon
sagen ich meine gerade die letzten
wochen haben es gezeigt dass vor allen
dingen die grünen eher sehr schwach aus
seinen der performance diese woche hat
es noch mal gezeigt da beginnt quasi das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium mit einer
bauchlandung und der bruchlandung es
geht um beispielsweise die finanzierung
für energieeffiziente sanierungen und
häuserbau ist das nicht dann einfach
auch etwas was derzeit ein großes
problem sieht für sie ist dass sie eher
schwach wirken auch in der
ampelkoalition
ich glaube in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung haben hier ein klares profil
gezeigt als grüne sowohl was gegen
koalitionsvertrag angehen und die vielen
projekten die dort verabschiedet wurden
klimaneutralität der 1,5 grad fans bau
der erneuerbaren oder aber auch die
kindergrundsicherung sind klare grüne
projekte für die wir in der opposition
so lange gestritten haben und jetzt sind
wir in regierungsverantwortung und
können das umsetzen und natürlich gibt
es die ein oder anderen dinge die in der
realität jetzt aufschlagen und die auch
intensiv und kompliziert sind sie haben
die belastung durch die verschärfung der
situation in der russland frage des
truppenaufmarsch es die ukraine
situation ja dass wir deeskalation und
diplomatie brauchen angesprochen aber
das greift ja gerade auf ein stück weit
genau das an was auch basis wurzel ihrer
partei ist dann müssen sie auf einmal
den spagat schaffen ob das
beispielsweise bei außenpolitischen
themen ist die grünen als pazifistische
partei natürlich auch in der langen
debatte wir haben das beim kosovo krieg
beispielsweise wir sind sie auch ein
heutiges prozess in gang gleichzeitig
kommen sie natürlich an in der ebene des
harten regierens und auf einmal müssen
sie ja auch dann ihre basis mit dem
anderes thema ist natürlich beim thema
klima sie verweisen jetzt auf das was im
koalitionsvertrag steht die grüner
ministerpräsident in baden württemberg
hat gestern in der debatte auch durchaus
kritisch gesagt dass sie als partei als
bündnis partei gestartet sind in den
wahlkampf und als milieu partei gelandet
sind also wo ist diese kritik berechtigt
teilen sie sich auch die einschätzungen
teilen von kretschmann es ist so dass
wir mit 14,8 prozent das beste ergebnis
erzielt haben was wir jemals hatten
natürlich hätten wir noch stärker werden
wollen das haben wir uns gewünscht aber
wir sind mit 118 abgeordneten im
deutschen bundestag vertreten wir machen
uns jetzt daran projekt für projekt
umzusetzen und zwar im interesse der
bürgerinnen und bürger und dazu gehört
aller vor dass die klimaneutralität die
klimapolitische eröffnungsbilanz von
robert habeck war ja
ganz offenkundig welchen rückstau
welchen rückstand wie hier durch die
vorgängerregierung übernommen haben das
wird eine riesenaufgabe für uns alle für
die gesamte gesellschaft für die
wirtschaft die unternehmen für uns als
partei und als andere und das sind
zentrale herausforderungen für uns wir
haben jetzt 125 1000 mitglieder wir sind
anziehen landesregierungen beteiligt und
wir fahren angestrebt regierung
beteiligt zu sein und wir werden jetzt
gemeinsam mit den bundesvorstand mitteln
mitglieder und aus der fraktion heraus
sehr selbstbewusst unsere rolle
wahrnehmen und uns an die umsetzung
dieser ampel vereinbarung machen und das
wird manchmal vielleicht einfach sein
wird so klaren standpunkt oder auch
widerspruch geben sie sind mir jetzt ein
bisschen sozusagen auf meiner frage
ausgewichen deswegen lass uns noch mal
anders zu stellen wie schwierig wird
denn der spagat eben genau diese robert
habeck sprach natürlich gestern ist aber
auch eine binse von der wichtigkeit von
kompromissen im regierungsgeschäft aber
wie wichtig wird das sein dass auch ihre
basis zu erklären man muss dazusagen
nach 16 jahren sind sie jetzt das erste
mal wieder in regierungsverantwortung
da kommt ja auch einiges an
kommunikationsarbeit danach auf den
neuen vorstand zudem wollte er gewählt
wird
wir haben alle eine neue rolle die sind
regierungsfraktion plötzlich der
bundesvorstand wird heute neu gewählte
ich wünsche allen ein wirklich starkes
ergebnis weil das beflügelt und gibt
rückenwind für die neue aufgabe und wir
haben als partei insgesamt mit den
landesverbänden mit den kommunal aktiven
vor ort eine neue andere aufgabe auch
unsere abgeordneten wir sind als
abgeordneter einer regierungsfraktion
die dinge zu verantworten hat die eine
bundesregierung auf den weg bringt und
ein parlament beschließt das verändert
das alles geht mit dialog mit diskurs
freude auch mit dem ringen um die beste
lösung und wir sind mir diskurs
freundliche partei und das werden wir
auch bleiben da bin ich ganz sicher eine
sache die auf die neue spitze zu kommen
heute stehen ja die wahlen an in einer
stunde schauen wir mal wieder parteitag
in seiner regie das auch dann möglich
macht von omid nouripour und ricarda
lang einmal es könnte ja durchaus auch
seien die ermittlungen der
staatsanwaltschaft die gerade laufenden
hinsichtlich von corinna zahlung an den
grünen parteivorstand ricarda lang war
er im bundesvorstand ist im
bundesvorstand
das ein stück weit auch eine bürde für
sie wird sich das unter umständen da gab
es ja auch kritische stimmen leise aber
doch heute das unter umständen auch sich
niederschlagen in dem wahlergebnis was
glauben sie mein eindruck ist dass nicht
das zu laufenden ermittlungsverfahren
äußerlich muss sowieso nicht der
bundesvorstand hat sich dazu geäußert
dass so viele borders gesagt das ist ein
klarer fehler war und ich glaube dass
mit ricaner lange an der spitze omid
nouripour die beiden haben ein super
angebot an die partei gemacht haben
deutlich gemacht wie viel wert die auch
diskus auf die parteiarbeit leben mit
den landesverbänden gegen kommunal
aktiven vor ort und ich glaube und hoffe
dass die beiden einen wirklich guten
start durch ein starkes ergebnis haben
sie stehen für die fraktion da sind ganz
viele junge mittel dabei sehen wir
gerade auch selber nochmal auf das
wahlergebnis verwiesen 14,8 prozent fast
verdoppelt das schlägt sich natürlich
auch in mandaten nieder wo sind die
größten herausforderungen zwischen
fraktionen zwischen regierung und auch
zwischen diesem neuen vorstand das zu
schaffen was omid nouripour im interview
schon nannte scharnier zu sein als
vorstand also was sind die größten
herausforderungen auf sich als grüner
warten und vielleicht auch situations
position ja natürlich gibt es ganz viele
erwartungen dass wir zum einen wie in
der ampel vereinbarten projekte umsetzen
dass wir vielleicht an der einen oder
anderen stelle auch noch ein grünes
projekt stärker
verarbeiten können rausbringen können in
den nächsten vier jahren und für uns ist
ganz wichtig als selbstbewusster große
vielfältige bunte und neue fraktion die
auch sehr weiblich ist und sehr jung
dass wir unseren klaren und eigenen
standpunkt haben und mit dem gefühl
unsere arbeit zu machen es muss nicht
unbedingt jeder gesetzentwurf so aus dem
parlament wieder rausgehen wie er von
der bundesregierung eingebracht wurde
und ich glaube diese selbstbewusste
haltung auch als parlamentsfraktion
steht den grünen sehr gut an sagt britta
haßelmann die die mehrheiten für ihre
partei in der im bundestag dazu
organisiert herzlichen dank das ist die
zeit genommen haben